feel like an 80s hair band or a 90
soccer mom hey guys it is Wednesday here
on its face or once over Wednesday for
short or oh pretty short I am in France
right now if you follow me on social
media you would have known that [ __ ]
idiot sorry older generation see France
very friend and you believe it almost as
beautiful as the grand can because I've
been traveling a lot and this summer I'm
doing a lot more traveling so today I
decided that I would answer some of your
travel questions that's appropriate my
hair looks like a wig someone turn down
the volume on this video but I'm going
to ask you guys for trouble questions
and now let's answer them how to find
good food places ask for good food
places concierge is or concierge a gaze
at hotels that's their job tour we can
simply walk into a food place and say
it's you good is you okay cooks I want
to know will answer there I tell you to
leave the restaurant and that's how you
know it's not a good restaurant what's
your favorite thing to do in a new place
drink from the menu bar and order room
service and then when I'm done with my
room service I like to push the leftover
food in front of a different person's
room so I don't look like I over ordered
who knows maybe look stumble home drunk
in there like oh yes I have a club
sandwich there is a god no it's me it's
me covering up my own gluttony how would
you pack for a trip to Estonia Estonia
ebooks and or audiobooks which brings
into a lovely segue
I've been plugging this I'm going to
continue to plug it audible.com they
I've offered me to offer you guys a free
download for an audiobook if you use the
unique your audible.com slash grace they
have a hundred and fifty seven thousand
books for you to choose and they're
really fun nice human
beings with a great company I am about
to download the secret diary of Lizzie
Bennet which it's double exciting
because it's actually narrated by
actually the growth plays Ashley
Clements the girl who plays Lizzie
herself so go to audible.com and get a
free download there it's very great when
you're traveling diarrhea on a plane
lovely human beings over at poo pourri
sent me a free package of a couple of
their products and I've used it for the
first time on this travel trip uh it
works real good you spray it before you
spray it from your butthole and the
coverage up sent it also sprayed it
afterwards and it covered up the scent I
am now not that comfortable with giving
you guys the visual of me [ __ ] 71
out there I was born out of butt hole
what do you do if you lose luggage while
traveling funny you should ask that
because I lost a bag on my way over here
which was unfortunate because it had all
my professional business clothes and I
have business things to do while I was
here so I had to scrounge whatever was
in my other bag which was my
miscellaneous clothing and put something
together to wear hence I've been wearing
the same things for the past couple days
but in the meantime gives you an excuse
to go shopping hey buds how does one get
through the purgatory that is a delayed
flight first choice
find a bar second choice um find a bar
third choice find a restaurant that
serves a fourth choice just leave the
airport some worth it go home and have a
drink by don't I travel more excellent
question
maybe it's an emotional fear you have of
traveling maybe you are uncomfortable
changing locations maybe you're just
[ __ ] lazy I don't know travel it's
good for your brain and also terrible I
almost like this weird thing where it's
so rewarding and so
like sex how does it not lose your
passport happens to me all the time I do
the same thing I recently lost my
passport I left my entire purse in the
Austin Airport because I'm an adult my
recommendation to you is to create a
mental checklist of the top three to
five things that you need and make sure
when you travel you're always going
through that checklist and realizing if
you do or do not have those things IDs
phone credit card then it's on to poo
pourri underwear socks how do you hook
up with people when you don't speak the
same language this is universal right
how do you deal with turbulence I'd like
to think that I'm not on a plane but
instead I'm in one of those massage
chairs in the middle of the mall great
it's working my lower back
how to survive a plane ride sitting next
to a farting old man let him have it
he's lived a long life how to make
waiting fun
what to pack for VidCon hand sanitizer
deodorant hope hey god I hope that
helped you in the my attempt to answer
your travel questions
go forth and rate this guidebook calm
remember I have a book that's available
for priests on them very excited about
it mmm I said Marian said very it's okay
I don't speak it all in this book